can garlic or vitamin C cure coronavirus
no does the virus only infect old people
no but we have all seen these or other
false claims online or on social media
there is an increasing number of fake
news about the corona virus outbreak
that are circulating in particular
online it's a massive wave breathing on
the ground of uncertainty anxiety and
the rapidly changing news cycle I'm
concerned that some of them can really
harm people for instant the false claim
that drinking bleach cures the virus
drinking bleach can be deadly
I'm also worried that those behind these
claims exploit people's fears about the
virus just to make money by selling them
very expensive soap for example that
allegedly kills coronavirus germs this
needs to stop
we are working with online platforms and
we encourage them to step up their
action against disinformation on the
corona virus the platforms are
facilitating access to trustworthy
sources such as public health
authorities and they demote and even
take down harmful content and
exploitative or misleading ads but more
needs to be done social media companies
need to share data with a fact-checking
community so that together we dismantle
these dangerous rumors we will continue
to monitor very closely action taken by
the platforms and we want to help you
check the facts we have launched a
special section on our website on the
corona virus response where you can find
information and facts about some of
these stories that you see trust your
health authorities trust the World
Health Organization trust reputable
media with the track record of accuracy
those spreading disinformation harm you
this information can cost lives but
together we can set the record straight